okay so we working on the arm right and
I got to keep my elbow on that same
plane on a plane vertical plane and my
wrist is on a
plane my elbow has to stay inside my
outer rim right I don't bring it
out okay and while it's drawing the
circles on that plane it's got to
rotate right okay so to help me get that
rotation at the beginning it's it's
easier if you pull your wrist
back and he
pushes push
so my
hand at the beginning level is going to
form like a teacup or or a flower cup
see my palm okay not not like that
here elbow
push okay let's
try e
to extension okay so when we're here I
don't I don't want to brace the angle my
foot okay see my back leg I kind of have
this kind of you know oval A-frame
go right that's not that's not correct
okay so I want to put weight on my back
on my back leg so I have to bend my
knee right there I have to bend my back
knee the exact opposite see when I
straight my back leg where's the weight
on my front leg okay so I want to ground
the back leg so the back leg has to bend
but more importantly the pelvis has to
tilt
see you see that oh is it not visible
with the
H okay I'm here when I start to lift my
pelvis up the back leg gets waiting okay
is it visible okay whereas the opposite
you see a lot of this see my pelvis is
pointed down okay and we want the
opposite right pelvis is pointed down so
we're
here pushing I don't want you to A-frame
him and take weight off the back leg I
want you to do the exact
opposite
good the more you
pushes the more I can lift that pelvis
and make the back foot heavier okay
let's try
that same
thing you see my pelvis pointing down
and I'm trying to A-frame it you see and
that's or I try to push
it you see how I'm doing that uh instead
I want his energy to come into me
so as as he pushes I
brown and I can add a little
pulse okay
you get do little
movement could be high part of it
tiny F pure
[Music]
try try and look down here
okay you
see my pelvis is
involved when this arm goes back the
pelvis goes back see that
boom absorb
[Music]
then the hand not
important you can't do
anything
get okay in this drill now you don't
want to Short change it
you're going to do that same thing
through his Center you have to
push so I I don't aim this over
here see I don't aim this behind
him
I push it through his center right I'm
looking there I have
to so make sure you're not not doing
that you see doesn't move
them right
through okay try
it okay so
tactically I am trying
to put him on that
angle that is the most efficient angle
for displacing him Topsy turby wise okay
I I need to get get that 45 the rolling
angle okay that that's what's happening
here so if he stays there right his
head's coming this way and and it's hit
it's gone that way you guys see that
that's what I'm that's why I'm doing the
inward spiral okay he's there his head
was going that way I'm going to do it
mechanically now and you get someone
going topy tur
okay there is a
small angle can olation on this arm here
too you see it's moving down and away
and all the benefits of rolling
regarding cross lateral checks okay but
before that I I need to get rid of that
cross leral shoulder so we do the other
spiroid the outward turn
spiroid and it's the same
thing my pelvis has to be involved
absorb
or but it has to happen as his grip is
coming
in and it can't just be my
arm you see the
difference and it has to aim through his
Center so the same
thing okay same keep your
grip same exact thing
I lock Palm the space between
us to get that
punch out of the way just to give me a
second
okay right as he
grips pelvis pelvis here here here here
here here not like
this see the difference okay pelvis
pelvis swim swim swim swim so at any
point you going to push through the
center
okay so so right if I if I was trying to
jump and touch the ceiling I don't go
like
this right I don't go with my hands
pulling
me what what do I have to do first press
down and then I can jump right I have to
press down right like remember the
Matrix when he was on all the
ground okay that's the same feeling so
you don't want to whether you're doing
the inward spiral right you don't want
to do that you got to go down into the
ground okay down into the ground boom
down into the ground boom down into the
ground
ground then from there right okay so
back to to
this as he comes to grab me I create the
Suki the hole that's where I move into
okay stke then I do the inward
spiral comes to grab Suki boom out we'll
just leave the in spiral there we'll
leave the lock
out hey how keep your gra boom h
so my body is flanking one two I'm
looking at him from that zon Sanctuary
right on the other side of the Cross
lateral shoulder you see that so make
sure you're not
here cuz you're not out of range you got
to move to the zone of sanctuary
the
45 close it move away from
it close it move away from it
okayy let's
try okay so it's the same inward spiral
right same inward spir but you're
forgetting things cuz you're moving so
first let's look at remember this is not
a he grabs and I do that because he can
do that
too okay I have to first close off the
angle so if he does that I I have the
pairing strike on this hand if I need it
okay and I still have the back
side so don't prioritize the strike at
that point prioritize the center line
you see whoever is dominating the center
line has the initiative has the
advantage he has to react to that and
he's getting a a step behind on the udoo
right so don't try and do that first
move close get at the center line so
don't try and hit some of you are
contemplating your motion CU you're
trying to hit here well your hands in
the center line and you're trying to hit
on the center line just be patient move
off boom there's the strip okay make his
face turn towards the shoulder you want
to do it open-handed you want to do it
back knuckle you want to do it vertical
irrelevant his chin has to go to the
shoulders so try to bring your right
shoulder toward me that's another check
on that you guys that okay now we go to
this part don't start missing his
Center you go through his
[Music]
Center Center Line waight Boom turn his
face around through his
Center Center Line
H you
okay let's go dominate the center line
back don't come to the
outside what what how did I start this
segment dominate what who has the center
line now he does he's more on the inside
than me you see I need my hand
here so my hand has to
be on the
inside not the outside okay
home
[Music]
hop okay try it again now remember it's
I hero so I
don't bring him one way and
then use be have that momentum and that
inertia used against me right so watch
what you're doing don't
zigzag okay that's beginner level okay
so is this
one very common so we have to look at it
he's going in and
around in and
around in and around can you see how I'm
making this flow now in and
around okay
now let's add some
other angles okay so we going going back
to
static we know what we're doing here
let's look at the other hand okay this
other hand comes up like it's going to
do
kneel so it has to grab in that
position you have your pinky and your
ring
finger on almost The Post
Line with the middle knuckle of your
thumb locked
into where the bones of the index
metacarpal and the thumb
right meet that V do you understand
right there okay so as he grabs that's
where that hand goes you'll notice I
leave the index finger open because that
tends to stop my palm from cupping and
creating that space there so you leave
the index finger open so your hand is
more flat on them okay so that hand goes
there this hand is doing everything the
same this hand is going to
pull and you'll have a small Nik
effect onto what you were already doing
which was moving him already but now you
create a better angle cancellation on
that shoulder remember I said when you
when you create that rolling geometry
right you have a small angle
cancellation on that shoulder remember I
said that okay so we want to increase
it so I'm pulling this don't worry okay
here see what I'm doing to this shoulder
see it's coming ahead of the other
shoulder
okay and when it does
that you start to cancel that other side
out more guys with me okay so
here this hand is home cutting through
the center this do that side and this
hand is pulling that shoulder
ahead okay that's what you're trying to
do so you this hand cannot do what this
hand is doing
this hand has to come
back this makes him light right and this
turns his
shoulder light
turn light
turn okay and now we put that into the
other part where we had the movement so
I close them
move close them
move and it's the same thing I don't
want to go back to
here
here I just threw all that weight at me
right his his momentum was coming this
way
and I want that to be redirected on a
circle so right if I if I don't do
anything there's a residual there you
see that CU he comes in so that's what I
want so the technique should get easier
okay you understand the Flow Part okay
you don't want to do you don't want to
have your e
behind that's that's crazy right I go
one way I pull into me and then and I go
like that right or I pull my
hand okay again like I always say if
you're that strong to throw a guy into
you and then push him you should have
just grabbed the front part of his face
and ripped it off right that's you're
that strong okay you're you're supposed
to
blend so which way was he coming in
which way he's going that way which way
should he be going that
way he's coming
in
okay so you have to to figure out how to
put all of these angles
together so that you're
not okay try it again